we're now being surrounded by Chinese
vessels they've sailed really really
close to us as close as a few meters
from us
and that's it looks like we have been
blocked and are stuck here
we are on board a Philippine Coast Guard
vessel in the South China Sea now this
is one of two Philippine Coast Guard
vessels escorting two Philippine Navy
chartered civilian boats
you can see that those two wooden boats
that's on either side of that other
Philippine Coast Guard vessel they're
carrying Provisions for troops stationed
on the BRP Sierra Madre which is a World
War II era Philippine Navy warship
that's been anchored on the second
Thomas Show to State the country's claim
in that area of the South China Sea now
the second Thomas Shoal is only 114
nautical miles from where we departed in
Palawan which is the westernmost
province of the Philippines but that
area is also being claimed by China
including almost the entire South China
Sea
and as we sail closer and closer to the
second Thomas Scholl we're now being
surrounded by Chinese vessels
in accordance with International and
Philippine national law we are
proceeding according to our France
Landry
they're two uh blue ships here suspected
Chinese and militia vessels we are also
being shadowed by white ones Chinese
postcard vessels and they've sailed
really really close to us
these Chinese vessels around us also
appear to be blocking our path
definitely we are seeing them right now
making an effort to block this current
resupply mission
and that's it looks like we have been
blocked and are stuck here but the
resupply ships have been able to make it
through China has said in the last few
weeks that they would let through
Philippine resupply boats for
humanitarian reasons but the Philippines
has refused to acknowledge this
narrative insisting that the Philippines
has a right to fortify its Outpost in
the second Thomas Scholl to provide
Provisions for troops stationed there
thank you